hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one would assume
that because the Stoics so value
tranquility and untroubled miss but then
and autumn axia as ideals as goals that
one of the things that they would be
greatly in favor of is a peaceful life
with as much leisure as possible but as
we're going to see
Epictetus thinks that those can lead us
astray that those are not really what we
want to be taking as goals so he talks
about this in book 4 chapter 4 of the
discourses and let's see what he
actually has to say about this he begins
by saying that the desires for four main
types of things place us in the power of
other people he's not saying this
exclusively of course desires for other
things places in in the power of other
people but these do as well and this
seems a little bit odd or
counterintuitive at first so the first
one is peace hey Suki is you know being
in a condition where one is left alone
where one is not being disturbed by
other people similar to that soul a the
word that we get school from which gets
translated as leisure in
times those who could afford to go to
school were people who actually had some
measure of leisure they didn't have to
work for a living although clay antes
provides us with an example of somebody
who had a day job carrying water and
then went and studied with Z know the
first stoic and other times of the day
at night travel I'm Houdini literally
it's sort of going away from your game
most going away from where you're from
and finally interestingly enough
scholarship fill ellonija Epictetus will
talk an awful lot about reading and
about books so doesn't this strike you
as a bit strange to hear a stoic
philosopher who's worked through those
words and ideas we're getting in these
books who spent a lot of time teaching
his students who references all these
great works of stomach literature that
we no longer possess telling us that
these things can become a trap for our
desires and actually make us unhappy how
is that the case well he's going to tell
us that with each of these they can
interfere with other things that we
consider to be valuable so here's to
give some examples
he says remember it's not merely desire
for office and wealth which makes men
abject and subservient others been
desired for peace these are traveling
scholarship it makes no difference what
the external object be the value you set
upon it makes you subservient to another
what difference does it make them for
you to set your heart on the Senate
something that would take a lot of work
or I'm not being a senator getting to
take it easy what difference does it
make to desire to office or to desire
not to hold office what difference does
it make to say I am a bad in a bad way I
have nothing to do but I am tied to my
books as though I were a corpse
that's what some scholars might be
saying or I am in a bad way I have no
leisure to read both of those are
equally bad if we're telling other
people and telling ourselves I don't you
know I can't get away I'm being
constrained by this stuff it's it's not
it's a sign that things have gone wrong
and he says what purpose do you read for
tell me if you turn into reading merely
for entertainment or in order to learn
something that's not really going to pay
off that much if you prefer reading to
if you refer reading to the proper
standard what else is this but a life of
serenity but just reading actually
secure for you that life of serenity
that you're after
he says for most people no now he also
points out a really important
distinction it's not just a lack of
leisure it's also leisure itself that
lies outside of the prior races the
Faculty of choice and the moral faculty
what it is that we have control over and
what we don't have control over now that
sounds a little strange because can't we
set up our day in such a way that we
will in fact have some time of leisure
or you know can't we set things up so
people won't be bothering us you know we
take the phone off the hook we don't
answer our texts oh you know don't don't
look at your email or Facebook or
anything like that yeah we can in fact
do that but that doesn't mean that we're
not necessarily going to get bothered by
something else and he's got some great
examples here he says what is this this
activity that you're doing that it makes
you so vulnerable to any chance thing
why do you get upset you know why are
you sort of investing yourself in
reading if reading can be interrupted by
all sorts of things
a crow by a crowd outside by the light
not working as well as this you want
he's really on to something there if we
desire for our what we might say our
free time or our time devoted to what we
think is is valuable if we desire that
too strongly that's not something that
we have control over so we make
ourselves vulnerable to being upset by
it if we're constantly working for that
if we set up the long term and I just
you know kind of keep working so I can
finally deserve that vacation when you
get the vacation it may not end up being
as great as the sacrifice that you made
ready to get there and then what's going
to happen you will be disappointed
vacations by the way often include you
know being alone being by yourself not
being bothered by people having leisure
time perhaps even beach reading right
people talk about that but think about
all the different things that epictetus
brings up that can easily go wrong so we
don't want to be any more attached to
these things as we do to their opposites
we don't want to be any more attached to
leisure as we are you know we don't want
to be any more attached to leisure as we
are averse to the lack of leisure you
could say do you think that what we do
especially with respect to reading and
with respect to reading in a stomach
philosophy we lose sight of what the
point of reading or study was now of
course a lot of our reading is perhaps
just for entertainment or to kill some
time in the airport or you know to
figure out how we're gonna play on our
next steps with our business or even any
of those sorts of management but you
don't think that if we are devoting
ourselves to learning philosophy and of
course that should be stoic philosophy
then there should pay off in a certain
way right how well the reading should be
preparation as he says
for the art of living not just technical
expertise but for thinking out how to
manage our life well how to live happily
which means for free of troubles which
means tranquil E which means able to
fulfill our duties to other people so
that's the point of reading the books
and he says that this is measured by
something other than works books
themselves cannot provide the standard
for measuring whether we ought to be
engaged in reading or not now if we
allow these sorts of things to become
too important for us we can you know get
quite upset
Epictetus says that we should be able to
take things as they come so whether
we're on our own
being undisturbed or in a crowd whether
we have leisure or whether we have the
opposite of leisure Australia business
time getting things done time we should
take that and not approach it in a
complaining bitter upset way constantly
bewailing what we're not giving these
things up here when we don't really know
what to do with them anyway instead like
he says we should be willing to you know
accept these sorts of things he says am
I to pass my life in this turmoil what
do you mean by terminal one among many
people what is there hard about that
imagine you are in Olympia regardless
turmoil as a festival this is how he
suggests we look at these sort of
matters there are two one man shouts
that and another this one man does this
and another that one man jostles another
there's a crowd and the bass and yet who
of us does not take delight in the
Olympic Festival and leave it with
sorrow
do not become peevish or fastidious
towards events don't say
we shouldn't say I don't like the the
vinegar because it's it's it's sour the
honey is rotten it upsets me I don't
like vegetables these common sort of
examples that fastidious eaters have
right this is in the same fashion you
say I don't like leisure
it's a solitude I don't like a crowd it
is turmoil that's why I have excuses
saying well what do you like why don't
you figure that out so you can actually
be happy what that means is figuring out
what in these things we really do desire
and then removing our desire from all
the other aspects of them what is it in
travel that we're really looking for
what is it in leisure that makes leisure
a good thing so it seems to us what is
it that being by ourselves and being
undisturbed by other people why does
that seem to be a good thing to us so
anything with reading why does that
appear to be a good thing it's not that
these things are good in and of
themselves it's really for the stoic
what we do with them so that lies within
the realm of our choice that is about
using things the crisis rather than
desiring the thing itself